[Música]
los últimos 15 años de mi vida he tenido
la dicha de poder estudiar la movilidad
en diferentes ciudades del mundo y estoy
convencido de que la salud de una ciudad
se puede medir por su calidad en el
transporte público y en la movilidad
activa si estos están deteriorados
la ciudad está enferma aquí veremos
algunos ejemplos de ciudades que están
haciendo grandes cosas para llegar a eso
a ese objetivo principal es tener una
movilidad sustentable
empecemos con londres
transport for london es la entidad
encargada de mover a todas las personas
en londres por cualquier medio de
transporte desde caminando hasta el
metro y basa su estrategia y sus
políticas públicas en datos tienen a 350
personas solamente para analizar la
ciudad las ciudades son entes vivos las
ciudades son dinámicas si no las metimos
no podemos mejorarlas por lo tanto no
han restar 25 años en simular todas las
calles de londres vías primarias vías
secundarias vías alternas todo londres
está simulado con datos actualizados por
lo tanto implementar políticas públicas
para ellos es muy sencillo comen o no
tan sencillo pero mucho más sencillo que
de este lado del charco
una de las políticas
una de las políticas que más me gusta es
esta gente struts sus calles saludables
por qué calles saludables que
necesitamos para tener calles saludables
cómo podemos bajar el estrés cuando nos
movemos y estás perforando en tiene algo
clarísimo algo clarísimo que me encantan
todos los viajes independientemente de
que el sistema de transporte utilicemos
inician y terminan caminando
para esto necesitamos tener precisamente
calles saludables
y si tomamos a los cargos como una
política pública de salud podemos lograr
estos beneficios al tener una activación
física
tenemos una disminución de enfermedades
en enfermedades coronarias y
cardiovasculares de hasta el 30%
diabetes tipo 2 hasta 50% quién lo diría
pero cáncer de colon cáncer de pecho 50
y 20 respectivamente fractura de cadera
hasta 68% de presión y esto lo sabemos
todos nosotros una calle caminando bien
diseñada nos va a reducir la depresión
nos va a reducir el estrés y esto se
traduce en de un 35 por ciento
al alzheimer algo increíble no y tenemos
este tipo de calles donde podemos
disfrutar convivir estar y permanecer
podemos reducir el alzheimer hasta 45%
uno de los sistemas de transporte
favoritos de transport for london son
los icónicos autobuses
estos fueron renovados con la última
tecnología de baja emisión contaminante
también se ha incentivado muchísimo los
viajes ciclistas a través de
infraestructura pero sobre todo
limitando la velocidad máxima en todo el
centro de londres a 30 kilómetros por
hora
a 30 kilómetros por hora todos podemos
convivir todos podemos compartir todos
podemos disfrutar la calle
otra política importantísima que tiene
londres es limitar los espacios de
estacionamiento
este edificio icónico de el distrito de
sitio a flor nunca es donde está la zona
financiera de londres saben cuántos
lugares de estacionamiento tiene
no hay un solo lugar de estacionamiento
para vehículos en este edificio hay un
piso en el subterráneo que es para
estacionamiento de bicicletas y hablando
de edificios cuando estos tienen una
gran extensión como este que es el
edificio de bloomberg en londres tienen
que tener un cruce peatonal para
disminuir las distancias de los viajes
en el centro del centro de londres
específicamente en el distrito de city
of london se ha limitado la circulación
de vehículos más bien se ha prohibido la
circulación de vehículos privados y
taxis de 7 de la mañana a 7 de la noche
de lunes a viernes
esto fue recientemente ampliado a un
perímetro mucho más amplio para reducir
las las partículas y gases contaminantes
esto nos permite crear calles mucho más
estrechas
me refiero a la superficie de rodamiento
con banquetas mucho más amplias y poder
tener arbolado puede rescatar espacio
público esto es un parque donde antes
había superficie de rodamiento y hay
otro proyecto muy importante que
se está realizando es un proyecto piloto
donde hay 50 estas secciones con
prioridad peatonal esto quiere decir el
semáforo siempre está en rojo vehicular
y en verde peatonal hasta que se
acumulan los vehículos automotores
entonces cambian a haberle vehicular
este es otra de esas intersecciones
vamos a dar para ciudad nos mudamos a
asia según se ha querido posicionar como
la ciudad
perdón es que desapareció aquí en mi
pantalla se usa como posicionar como la
ciudad sustentable en el mundo y para
esto os voy a explicar dos productos
icónicos de la de esta gran urbe de más
de ocho millones de habitantes
esto era una barranca este proyecto son
jason roberts era una barranca por algo
los setentas se construye un viaducto
elevado sobre la barranca lo que trajo
contaminación sin estos viales
congestionamiento e incluso delincuencia
con un trabajo enorme de sociabilización
del producto y con una política integral
de transporte público mejorando el
transporte estructurado e implementando
líneas de beret nuevas líneas de bp se
luego de hacer en el 2000 un parque
lineal se derribó este este viaducto
elevado se puso este río es un río
artificial donde purifican el agua donde
termina y la vuelven insertar al inicio
es este punto precisamente y lo que lo
que ha provocado es una reducción en
gases contaminantes pero además se ha
vuelto en una en un enfriador de la
ciudad ha logrado bajar
la temperatura de la zona de forma muy
importante caminar lo es una una
maravilla es un placer caminar por aquí
es un espacio no solamente para caminar
60 mil personas lo visitan a diario
tenemos exhibiciones de arte tenemos
incluso aquí por ejemplo me tocó una una
pasarela una pasarela de modas sobre el
río isabela la alfombra roja y en los
puentes son los bajopuentes se exhiben y
se exhiben otra vez obras de arte o se
tienen conciertos o incluso obras de
teatro es un lugar vivo es un lugar para
todos eso es un lugar humano
este es otro proyecto 20 70 17 tuve la
fortuna de que se acaba de inaugurar
cuando llegué en un hecho lo vi en una
revista del hotel y por supuesto me fui
directo va a verlo es el sueño hasta se
me pone la piel chinita es el sueño de
muchos de los que nos dedicamos a esto a
construir ciudades más humanas esto es
un adulto dorado otra vez es un segundo
piso así los conocemos aquí de
novecientos treinta y ocho metros casi
un kilómetro a 16 metros de altura donde
se rescató este lugar para hacer un
parque lineal con accesibilidad
universal es decir cualquier persona
aunque tenga alguna discapacidad puede
acceder a él sí se encuentran 52
familias de especies vegetales en 645
macetas sumando más de 24.000 plantas
es un museo vegetal impresionante
cada una de estas macetas tiene una
placa que describe la planta o la
especie está sembrada y éstas están
seleccionadas no tenemos la zona de las
rosas la la zona de los lirios por
ejemplo y es un placer recorrerlo la
ciudad se disfruta de una manera
maravillosa a 16 metros de altura cuando
nos vamos a bordo de un vehículo
y por último les quisiera platicar de
parís parís al igual que según está en
esta carrera por la lucha de ser
nombrada la ciudad más sustentable en
este caso de europa han hecho un trabajo
formidable en los últimos años con la
implementación de políticas públicas y
la aplicación de las mismas de una
manera brillante
han creado esta política pública de
entornos escolares seguros residentes y
amigables con el medio ambiente llevan
761 de ellos ya realizados y concretados
hay más de 800 islas de enfriamiento con
al menos 50 árboles 20.000 nuevos
árboles tienen proyectados para el 2020
y 202 hectáreas de techos verdes
quieren ser una ciudad neutra y con 100%
de generación de energía renovable en el
2050 un reto sin precedentes en la
historia de las ciudades y por supuesto
el gran rescate del río sena y las
calles aledañas
como hemos visto una ciudad no puede ser
sustentable sin priorizar la
peatonalización simples a este bajo
estrés en las calles sin revisar a los
usuarios vulnerables así vemos alrededor
de todos londres calles donde el
invitado es el vehículo y el dueño de la
calle o el que tiene la mayor prioridad
son las personas otra cosa que me llamó
la atención por supuesto es como
incentivan en los viajes ciclistas esta
es la zona de montmartre ya saben la
capilla de bala y en todas sus calles
tenemos zonas de teoría ciclista bien
prácticamente todas tenemos carriles de
contraflujo ciclistas pero tenemos esta
falsa crítica de esteban ciclista en
sentido contrario no se da mucho aquí en
san pedro cholula y yo les explico que
los viajes ciclistas son viajes físicos
son como los viajes peatonales implican
un esfuerzo físico por lo tanto siempre
vamos a buscar la menor distancia para
realizarlos
otra cosa que han hecho de irache muy
bien ese sistema de bici público el
believe para mí uno de los mejores del
mundo y para mí cuando los más bellos
del mundo
es tan famoso y tan icónico ya en
londres y en parís ya hasta cuenta con
souvenirs como estos podemos
conseguirlas en las tiendas que se
dedican a esto y ha llegado a los
sistemas de bicis sin estación y los
scooters eléctricos en recientes tiempos
el haber podido circular parís 17
kilómetros diario en scooter eléctrico
con mi hijo la persona que amo y adoro
que aparece en la foto sin ningún
peligro
es una experiencia única y además nos
demuestra que parís está haciendo bien
las cosas
están incentivando también el
estacionamiento para vehículos
eléctricos y esto es importantísimo las
zonas de calor
estas islas de calor que son un
beneficio enorme quien no quisiera
calles así que a ver cuántas pueden
identificar de cámara las ciudades de
donde vienen cuántas calles pueden
identificar con este arbolado
las zonas de enfriamiento consisten en
sembrar al menos 50 árboles en un área
muy reducida y con esto lo que logramos
es producir hasta dos grados la
temperatura del barrio donde tenemos las
zonas de enfriamiento una reducción de
dos grados en un barrio nos provoca una
disminución de 3 por ciento de muertes
durante las horas de calor también nos
controlan las micropartículas
contaminantes y nos gestionan el agua de
lluvia cada vez que ustedes se
encuentren por cualquier medio de
transporte ya sea que vayan caminando
que vayan en bici que vayan en
transporte público o en vehículo
particular cuando se encuentren en una
inundación
en la calle piensen en esta imagen
piensen en los árboles los árboles nos
gestionan el agua ayuda es urgente
implementar políticas públicas de
arbolado en nuestras ciudades
estas son las calles aledañas el río
sena
y acaban de ganar una batalla legal
épica contra usuarios de vehículo
particular está esta calle era hoy no
parece no puesta cayeron a una calle
vial en una calle donde circulaban miles
y miles de vehículos diariamente
se abrió para las personas
y ahora es una calle donde podemos ir no
solamente hacer ejercicio tanto
caminando corriendo en bicicleta donde
tenemos espacios estar para convivir
para vernos a los ojos cuando nos vemos
a los ojos creamos ciudad
creamos convivencia creamos seguridad
tenemos espacios para todas las edades y
para todos los géneros tenemos espacios
de convivencia
espacios que podemos disfrutar espacios
que podemos vivir
esto es muy curioso porque esta calle
nos lleva a un deprimido como de 2 km y
es impresionante ir en un túnel en
bicicleta viendo todos primero la
entrada esta no viendo a todos los
vehículos atascados ahí en sus dos
carriles y los ciclistas y los
corredores y demás circulando libremente
por estas casi ancho de tres carriles
entramos un túnel imagínense un túnel
ciclista de dos kilómetros de tres
carriles es impresionante
para construir los ánimos de la
movilidad urbana sustentable impacte en
términos de salud pública nos impacta en
términos de contaminación de efecto
invernadero de siniestros viales de
habitabilidad de residencia y por ende
en la calidad de vida no podemos seguir
postergando la implementación de
políticas públicas integrales como las
que hemos analizado es una cuestión de
humanidad es una cuestión de tener un
lugar donde vivir no solamente para las
generaciones futuras sino para las
presentes muchísimas gracias
[Música]
bien